Cloud9 looked like the best North
American team in valorant right now
maybe even the best team in the entire
league everyone expected them to flop
after dropping yay and vanity before the
season started so how the hell are they
pulling this off
[Music]
all right everyone before we get into
the episode I just want to give a shout
out to our partners at Qualcomm
Technologies and the Snapdragon Elite
Gaming Team they're helping us explore
mobile Esports and the mind-blowing
technology that's the driving force
behind it so if you want to learn more
about that make sure you check out our
cracked episode on the explosive rise of
mobile Esports using the link below and
stay tuned as we head to the Snapdragon
Pro Series mobile Masters in Tokyo
alright so a couple months back I made a
video titled what the happened to
Cloud9 the team had just robbed yay and
vanity only two weeks before the start
of the season and even as a C9 fan it
was really hard for me to stay
optimistic C9 released a video where
they cited role issues as the main
reason behind the decision but everyone
thought that it was especially
after yay tweeted this and then deleted
it the team then signed two relatively
unknown players in Rooney and Jake and
not many people had any sort of
expectations for this roster Rooney was
previously the igl for Sonics and
narrowly missed out on Challengers but
was most known known for being called a
disgusting well by T-Dog on Twitter and
Jake was playing Collegiate valorent for
UST so it makes sense that people were
counting them out before the season even
started and even when they won their
Opening match everyone sort of ignored
it because EG were also getting meme to
do Oblivion at the time but then they
took a pretty convincing map win against
the defending world champions loud in
week two they didn't win the series
against loud but it was definitely a
sign of things to come since then C9
have taken down every team they faced
only dropping a single map and each and
every week they've continued to look
better and better it could be a bit of a
drop play because I don't expect tickets
oh my goodness dude I don't know that it
might be arguing to get out of this
outstanding what a mess
what a mess
now there are a number of reasons why I
think Cloud9 has been able to prove
everyone including myself wrong Leaf has
been moved back onto primary do list and
he and zeppa have been fragging out the
entire season as we've just come to
expect and Celsius has been a rock on
killdroid but the biggest surprise has
to be the new guys Jake and Rooney
despite having no tier one experience
they look like some of the best players
in the entire league and their
respective roles they're the real deal
MCE has put on another Master Class
scouting these players and developing
them into top talent similar to what he
did with Trent and the guard last year
Jake even credited his coaching style
for a lot of their success one of his
main strengths is his ability to know
like what the other team's doing but he
doesn't necessarily create an emphasis
on that just the small things that they
do oh Kalia likes the TP over here and
be Main and it's so small things that
we're able to figure out and isolate and
shut them down and that shuts down their
main game plan early on also his
sterness as a coach when you make a
mistake he just yells at you straight up
like and you know when you made that
mistake and you know you're about to get
Yoda and you know you want to fix it for
next time and that's super super
important in a coach I think sometimes
coaches don't have that sternness and
you don't the players don't want to
listen to them as much and I think Matt
is just really great because of that now
MCE being the humble guy that he is
didn't want to take all of the credit so
he spoke more about his scouting
techniques following c9's win against
Sentinels a few weeks back Player
Development only goes so far like these
players were already good to begin with
it's about giving people a chance and a
lot of people like that came from the
other game we had played including
myself zelsus leave uh zeppa like they
were just as good in the previous game
and never got a chance or they got one
chance it wasn't a good chance so it's
like there's certain uh characteristic
traits that you look for and there's a
lot of tier two and tier 3 players that
would surprise people if they were given
the chance but it's of those guys who
doesn't have the ego who wants to work
who wants to be a part of something you
know bigger than themselves and that's
what you have to look for MCE and cupert
have these guys playing like a
well-oiled machine but another reason
for their success is their Eco round win
percentage C9 are consistently winning
Thrifty rounds with Sheriff's frenzies
and stingers zelsus zeppa and leaf had
the most Stinger kills in all the VCT
leagues after week five and Cloud9 had
the highest eco-round win percentage too
according to the stats courtesy of
willminder and run it back I spoke with
willminder yesterday and he confirmed
that C9 are still in that number one
spot with a 32 Thrifty win rate after
week six these guys are playing so well
that patchat even moved them to the
number one spot on their power rankings
last week and I know a lot of people
were confused by that decision because
loud is still undefeated but we got to
keep in mind that these are indeed power
rankings despite remaining undefeated
after week six loud have played some
very close matches and they've often
Fallen victim to slow starts now some of
you might be thinking that I'm just
spouting C9 copium and well yeah I'm a
C9 fan but we're genuinely at the point
where you can make the argument that
they're playing like the best team in
the league we might not get to see that
rematch until the playoffs if it even
happens but heading into the season I
wasn't exactly confident that C9 would
even make the playoffs and now they're
in the discussion for the best team in
the region I still feel bad for yay and
vanity but if Cloud9 makes Tokyo then I
don't think any of us can really
question that extreme decision again
for the end board I actually yeah I just
wanted to give a shout out to my Premier
team we got our first dub yesterday on
Pearl we put on an absolute
master class on Pearl 13-4 dub
um just want to give a shout out to my
team let's carry that momentum into
Saturday on bind and let's let's make a
push for playoffs hashtag Elizabeth
Sports
yeah this is this is our uh our team
manager